[Music]
this is eleanor
the motherland's youngest trainee all
she wanted was to be a real fairy
godmother
recite it with me please
i know that i can do this i'm gonna
prove that people still
need fairy godmothers
i'm looking for mackenzie walsh let's
see what we can find
siri search mackenzie walsh okay
here's what i found who said that is
there a genie in there
don't answer that i'm looking for a sad
little girl named mackenzie walsh
that is me no it can't be you you're
old have you seen yourself security
me again i'm your fairy godmother back
off lady
morning oh good you're awake too
is this your true love not anymore life
isn't always a fairy tale
i came all this way to help you find
your heart's desire you know what you
need
the makeover what what have you done to
my eyebrows
magic my house i know right
i turned my dog into a pig this bell got
away from me
oh it's okay he's just here to help with
the housework
life isn't as simple as happily ever
after fine after all nine out of ten
fairy tales begin with once upon a time
something amazing happened while she was
drinking wine
in her sweatpants i've been trapped in
the fairy tale when the real world is
full of so much more
you're starting to believe in magic
aren't you
are you sure i can't make you a ball
gown before i go okay please wait no
please don't
oh no
nice dress is it new don't be mad don't
[Music]
huh
[Music]